Sunday senator Kamala Harris who has
been cribbing Bernie Sanders cheat sheet
in order to position herself for a 2020
Democratic presidential run tweeted out
her feelings on the possible
restructuring of Medicaid under the
Senate health reform bill she tweeted
quote Americans won't lose their health
care it's not like we left it on the bus
the Republicans are taking it from us
don't take our stuff needless to say
this is imbecilic
Kamala Harris is right nobody will be
losing their health care they didn't
leave it on the bus because it's not a
physical commodity and it was never
their stuff those on Medicaid had a
grant from the government taken from
redistributed money to help pay for
their health care which they obtained by
pressuring doctors to provide it at low
reimbursement rates it wasn't theirs any
more than unemployment benefits or yours
or welfare is yours or any other
redistribution out a redistributed
outcome is yours health care is a series
of goods and services that belong to
someone else until you pay for them in
an exchange mutually agreed by the two
sides my wife is a doctor her labor is
not your stuff that would make her an
indentured servant
she has sung some nine years of her life
fee to becoming a doctor four years of
college four years of medical school and
now she's just completed her first year
of residency
that means we spent hundreds of
thousands of dollars on her education
and she spent countless hours working
away from home studying and the like
network is not yours it is in Kamala
Harris's the sense of entitlement behind
Democratic policy is simply
mind-boggling more importantly it's
actually counterproductive declaring
someone else's labor yours doesn't make
it magically appear Paris seems deeply
concerned about cuts to Medicaid
apparently she's not aware the Medicaid
outcomes are generally no better than
uninsured outcomes and the doctors are
dropping out of Medicaid coverage day in
and day out thanks to government's
failures the moment you declare someone
else's services yours they stop
providing them but by invoking that
sense of entitlement Harris merely
ensures that you'll increase her
popularity
unfortunately it is political catnip to
tell people that things that don't
belong to them actually do
that's how Democrats gained power even
as they destroy the services they
supposedly seek to provide and Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
everything is stupid oh yeah that's
right it's another day another glorious
day and everything is intensely stupid
we'll get to president Trump and the WWE
and him playing 5g Hungry Hungry Hippos
and the whole deal we'll get to all of
that and then the media losing their
minds and shouting not sick about
everything is you know I tweeted last
week that each night I go to bed and I
think things can't possibly get any
stupider and then I wake up the next
morning and I thank God things were so
much smarter last night and yes yes
indeed that prophecy has come true
spoken in the book of Deuteronomy and
now repeated by me or paraphrase by me
everything is intensely stupid we'll get
to all of the very very stupid things
and we have a plethora of stupid things
to talk about but before we do that
let's not the Betty smart thing and that
is ring.com so if you are concerned
about home security as well you should
be because it's an unsafe world out
there the ring video doorbell helps
protect your home so the way this works
is that you install at your front door
people ring the doorbell and then
instead of it just ring doorbell inside
the house because home burglars like to
check if you're home and then if you're
not then they break in instead it rings
to your phone so you can answer you can
see who's at the front door there's a
camera there you can answer as though
you're home ring nose home security
begins at the front door but it doesn't
end there so now they're actually
extending that same level of security to
the rest of your property with the ring
floodlight cam so just like rings
amazing doorbell flood like heavens
motion-activated camera and floodlight
that connects right to your phone with
HD video and to a audio the lets you
know the moment anyone steps on your
property you can see speak to visitors
and even set off an alarm from your
phone with floodlight cam when things go
bump in the night you will know exactly
what it is
ring floodlight offers a fantastic deal
in home security with high visibility
flood lights and that powerful HD camera
again with ring you are always home save
up to one hundred and fifty dollars one
hundred fifty bucks off a ring of
security kit when you go to ring comm
slash Ben ring comm slash Ben so ring
complex pending one hundred fifty bucks
off the ring of security kit which we
have at our house we use it all the time
ring calm / Ben and then also let's let
me know that we say used to make sure
use that / Ben when you go over to ring
comm check it out alrighty so president
Trump on Friday so you recall then on
Friday president Truong
tweet it out or Thursday he tweeted out
about mika brzezinski and her bloody
facelift and everybody said oh and of
the world it's so terrible and we said
this is not presidential this is not
great because it's not because it's kind
of schmucky so but does President Trump
back off no this is a man who bites he
fights he fights sort of like the boxer
punching himself in the face repeatedly
but he fights he fights sort of like a
man he stuffs coins into into a sock and
then smash himself in the groin as Jonah
Goldberg says but he fights okay so
there are a lot of people on the right
who are saying oh he fights and he's
destroying the media now here's what's
happening he is destroying himself and
the media are destroying themselves and
they're both destroying themselves and
America sits over here and laughs
because the WWE
so on Saturday Trump to each out my use
of social media is not presidential
it's modern-day presidential make
America great again okay first of all we
got to slogan okay like at a certain
point Matt got Magda Magda Magda Magda
it becomes tiresome because your tweets
are not making America great again okay
they're not I'm sorry they're not they
may have helped you during the campaign
that's great lots of things that help
you during the campaign do not help you
when you become president as barack
obama learned but I love that it's
modern-day presidential tomorrow is July
4th brought to you by such presidents as
George Washington and Abraham Lincoln
and now modern a presidential is is this
so demonstrating just how modern-day
presidential all this is Trump tweets
this out on on Saturday this is really
he tweeted this out
hey if you cannot see what this is it is
Trump from the WWE when he's in the WWE
Hall of Fame and this is Trump tackling
some dude and somebody hits somebody
from reddit to this they pasted into the
meme a logo of the CNN head and then
Trump tackling CNN and pummeling CNN
clotheslining CNN and pummeling it so
okay your first reaction has to be laugh
because it's really frickin funny okay
it's just inherently this is all insane
we now live in idiocracy which came half
a century too early it's all crazy okay
everything is crazy we have reached peak
stupid or you know I think that every
time I think we've reached peak stupid
it turns out that there's another hill
yet to climb it's sound of music climb
every mountain you know literally every
time we reach peak stupid like we look
up and there's 300 more feet of stupid
yet - yes a surmount it's pretty amazing
so Trump tweets this out I mean tweets
out cached ad fraud news DNA is one of
call them fake news anymore who thinks
fraud news is better which I don't
really know why but in any case you're
right hashtag fraud News CNN and then he
and all hell breaks loose because the
President of the United States has done
something deeply awful so a couple of
notes on the deeply awful thing first of
all his followers immediately go oh my
god it's the greatest thing that ever
happened it's just a pillar what a
genius no just no okay just no it's not
no okay it's hilarious but it's
hilarious like dumb and dumber is
hilarious okay I love the movie Tommy
Boy Tommy Boyd my parents think I'm an
idiot for liking the movie Tommy Boy I
think movie Tommy Boy is hilarious but
Chris Farley and David Spade think it's
really funny but it is not the greatest
thing that the love child of Chris
Farley and David Spade in that movie is
now tweeting from The Oval Office
apparently like that's weird okay it's
weird and it's not great and again John
Adams once rounded on the day that he
occupied the White House he wrote a
letter to his wife they made none but
good and honorable men occupy this
office mm-hmm so in any case Trump
tweeted this out and his followers like
yeah because this meeting does the I
that get it cuz gettin stupid super
that's the old PID stupid and then CNN
response is CNN they gotta win here
right I mean CNN can't just sit here and
go my God my god but instead what they
decide to do is lose their minds CNN
decides that it is important they can't
just say this is dumb the Cantor state's
unpresidential which it is they can't
just say it's sort of disgraceful to the
Oval Office I mean listen this is not
the only disgrace that ever happened to
the Oval Office Bill Clinton you know
that his his juices spread around the
Oval Office so there were a fair number
of things that have happened in the Oval
Office that have been great but is this
you know is this elevating the discourse
is this elevating America is this a good
is this good role modeling from our
leadership no no it no not so much okay
but instead of Democrats are saying that
it's em Democrats saying you know this
is really incompetent like the President
of the United States should spend his
time talking about important things and
bringing the country together and
instead he's tweeting out this kind of
silly crap right instead of them doing
that they go to eleven right they always
go to eleven on the spinal tap on the
spinal tap machine that's gonna Levin on
those speakers and now it turns out that
not only is this just stupid it's not
just stupid and and dim-witted and
ridiculous and hilarious it's not just
any of those things know Donald Trump is
a threat to the Republic so here comes
here comes schoolmarm brian Stelter over
on CNN to warn America Trump is going to
come and he's gonna clothesline you just
like he clothesline that logo of CNN or
something Lord okay all right
the president is grappling with Senate
Republicans who miss a self-imposed
deadline on health care he's preparing
for a staredown this week with Russian
President Vladimir Putin but on Twitter
he's wrestling with hi within this video
from his Twitter account this morning
this is a WWE WrestleMania video from
years ago you can see that the CNN logo
has been superimposed onto the other
fighters face
now this showed up on a reddit message
board days ago now it's showing up on
the President of the United States own
Twitter feed the early reactions in the
last 90 minutes of range from this is
juvenile ridiculous idiotic oh wait no
it's just funny he's just having fun
away no it's actually scary dangerous
we've heard a wide range of reactions to
this the first CNN's response the
strongest statement I've seen from CNN
or any news outlet this year in response
to the president
tax quote it is a sad day when the
President of the United States
encourages violence against reporters
clearly Sarah Huckabee Sanders lied when
she said the President had never done so
okay let's stop it okay it's okay so
that it's just okay so yes if you watch
that video and what you got from that is
someone on a punch brian Stelter okay
then you're an idiot
you're an idiot so two weeks ago they
Trump hating Bernie Sanders supporter
went and shot up a bunch of Republican
Congress people and try to assassinate
dozens of them and I said on this
program the Democrats were not openly
calling for violence so I'm not going to
blame Democratic rhetoric for a nutjob
trying to shoot people and now in CNN
said the same thing right and now
they're turning around they're saying
Trump's going to get us all killed
because he tweeted out an idiotic WWE
wrestling meme CNN so here it's
basically here's the cycle of
conversation now Trump's tweet something
stupid indefensible ridiculous quasi
vile the media then says it's not enough
to say that it's all those things he's a
Nazi a violent evil Nazi Nazi Nazi and
then everybody goes okay well I guess
I'm not that I guess like if I have to
choose between these two people I guess
Trump sweeter than that bad I mean like
really guys like seriously but the
entire media because they can't help it
they keep looking for the kill shot and
this is the problem okay they keep
looking for whatever is going to somehow
else Trump from office and they think
every time he tweets this is now
impeachment for neither time has come
and to get brian Stelter saying this is
like Google Chavez or receive type odo
on like the Decatur of Turkey or
Vladimir Putin is this president trying
to impersonate Hugo Chavez rest up tie
up Irwin Vladimir Putin because this is
exactly the kind of language the leaders
use when they are trying to undermine
the press if you put on air to be
anything else more free not some
reporters imitating edit okay okay shut
them up is such stupidity I mean really
pansy pansy stuff from Siena and then it
continues to CNN's Jim Acosta comes I
says someone's going to get hurt don't
you understand someone will die because
Crump tweeted out a meme of himself from
the WWE fake wrestling event tackling a
logo see if
oh it's all so stupid
it's so intensely stupid I've lost all
capacity to speak intelligently about
something so intensely stupid the more
you watch the news more IQ points you
lose by the time if this continues for
another six months we will all be
clinically brain-dead from losing as
many brain cells it is fully fully
insane okay here is Jim Acosta saying
someone will get hurt someone all right
Jim there are two approaches to this one
is we can just sit back and be silent
and just take it there are some people
who say you know don't take debate
you're just going to encourage this
behavior even more but I think we're
well past that now I think we're at the
stage where we have to try the it will
pass that it's too dangerous we have to
okay first of all you have a third
choice which is to treat the tweet like
it is it's Trump who's not world's most
intelligent man contrary to what his
public thinks okay tweeting something
that his unbridled volatile aide told
him to tweet and it doesn't mean
anything
because he's just Trump any tweets
things and he says stuff and by the way
his defenders should say this this would
be the best defense for Trump is the man
just says stuff ready gets up in the
morning and while he's peeing he watches
Morning Joe and then he's mad and then
he tweets the thing and then we all go
on with our day because guess what
nothing has changed has anything
markedly changed since January except
everything has gotten supremely stupid
like even more stupid than it was last
year
you thought the 2016 was stupid and then
2017 came along this whole might be our
okay Martha Raddatz on ABC shows the
same things it seemed like a threat to
me it seems like a threat I mean I'm
feeling I'm feeling scared and fragile
okay someone who receives death threats
on a fairly regular basis a death threat
sounds like someone calling up your
phone and saying I'm gonna come to your
house and murder you it doesn't sound
like a meme where somebody tackles you
okay not even a meme or somebody has you
in a gas chamber pushing a button okay I
get hundreds of those okay this one is a
meme literally of the logo like it would
be like a sauna took the daily wire logo
and had and had Bernie Sanders tackling
it when I feel threatened by that or and
I just say this is the stupidest crap
I've ever seen but the media oh no we
have to we have to play wounded was a
real threat is a threat to Liberty ABC's
Martha Raddatz he certainly can't
communicate to the people but I want to
ask you is has the kind of communication
you want that he's beating up on
somebody well hitting or getting up on
the media you're in charge of Homeland
Security there you know that seems like
a threat yes certainly not though I
think that no one would perceive that as
a threat I hope they don't but I do
think that he's beaten up in a way on on
cable platform and then the right
response of course we'll get to the
right response in a second because the
right basically the left has lost its
mind the right is losing its pool it's
old so those are basically the two
things that are happening right now the
stupidest response came courtesy of our
friend Sally Cohen so Sally she
responded saying is there no line have
you no decency sir ah let me make point
then I asked a question so I actually
can't believe this is happening uh it
was Donald Trump who said that Barack
Obama wasn't a citizen of this country
it was Republicans who said he had a
Kenyan colonialist mindset that
literally questioned his legitimacy to
even be in the White House had President
Obama gone to a veteran's effect Kaleigh
a veteran's event and used that event to
attack the media you you'd be all over
with angular no no no no no I love you
that's right now it's my turn
so I can't believe you can defend I mean
really is there is there no so my
question is is there no lie like if that
had been a picture not of a CNN logo or
video not of the San and logo but it had
been Jake peppers head he was punching
would that cross a line for you what if
what it was a picture of Donald Trump
holding a bloodied CNN logo of you
exactly when does a crown line when
delivery when does it hello okay I have
a question Sally when does this cross
the line okay you tweeted this a week
ago one week ago quote troubled
Wisconsin man goes on 50-state killing
spree and it's a picture of Paul Ryan
and this is why the right has gone into
this this routine of what about ISM
which is okay well the media have been
doing all this sort of violent threats
for years and now all of a sudden
they're very upset I want to talk a
little bit more about this but first I
want to say thank you to our sponsor is
over at five
four clubs so if you do not know how to
dress well but you need to help us some
who doesn't know how to dress well
that's where 5'4 Club comes in five four
Club is revolutionizing the way the men
shop for clothing so each month they
send you a curated box of two to three
items hand-picked to match the current
season and your style well you go over
to the website you tell them what kind
of clothes you are looking for your sort
of color palette they've been helping
men with fashion for over 15 years and
they ship to over 100,000 men every
single month they've already sent me a
pack and it is just fantastic when you
look good you feel good that is just a
fact of life it's one of the reasons why
I have upped my style game with five for
club as a 5-4 club member you receive
50% off items in their online shop and
access to exclusive Members Only items
free shipping in size exchanges and
their clothing is a lot more inexpensive
than then if you go to a brand outlet
because and they have the exact same
designers right now you get 120 dollars
worth of clothes for just $60 a month
120 dollars worth of clothes for $60 a
month you can pause or cancel anytime no
commitments all you have to do is go to
five four club.com right now that's five
for club.com right now when you enter
promo code ben they'll give you 50% off
your first month package plus a free
pair of sunglasses so 50% off your first
package at 5 for club it's spelled out
so FIV e fo you are club.com 5 for club
comm promo code ben and again you get
that 50% off your first month package
plus a free pair of sunglasses all sorts
of celebrity G's 5 for club Chris Paul
Mark Wahlberg it's featured in all the
fashion magazines it's really cutting
edge of designers terrific clothing so
check out five four club.com and then
make sure you use that promo code Ben so
that they know that we say you can get
50% off your first month order and it is
just great looking stuff okay so one of
the reasons the right has responded to
Trump's tweet the way they have is
because the right looks at this and they
say okay so in an ideal world would be
like over the moon the Trump tweets this
kind of stuff no but is but on the other
hand Kathy Griffin Trump bloody head
Julius Caesar
performance Trump being killed the the
CNN coverage with the sort of the
spotlight over Trump's head you know
there's been a lot of violent nasty
rhetoric surrounding Trump
since the election cycle so what's so
wrong with
we'll discuss what's wrong with that in
just a second because I think that there
is a a problem with the general notion I
think there's a problem with the general
notion that when it comes to the
rhetoric that you use we are no longer
in retaliatory mode we're now in offense
mode so well if the Left weren't even
doing this I think the right a lot of
members of the right would be
celebrating this sort of stuff but how
should the media really be responding to
this well the way the media should be
responding to this is the way that David
Barron whole to the New York Times
responded to this so here's David
Farenthold he was on a panel on on CNN
about this and here's what he had to say
David I also remember president-elect
Trump saying that he was going to limit
his use of Twitter once he gondhali was
going to be restrained he said he said
yeah if I even get on Twitter it'll be
restrained does all of this surprise you
no not at all
look this is dumb it's a dumb thing to
have tweeted it's not a very
presidential thing to tweeted but listen
everybody else in the world has learned
from this the foreign leaders that Trump
insults on Twitter the companies that he
goes after on Twitter they've all
realized that it's it's mostly just talk
it's just a guy talking is yelling at
the screen he's expressing this anger
and they've begun basically to ignore it
if you look at McCrone Merkel leaders of
China
companies like carrier the Trump was
harassing earlier on they've all managed
to sort of put it aside and focus on
whatever they were going to be doing
what Sharon Holt says is exactly right
okay over he's active Washington Post
nothing York Times my mistake so he what
he says here is exactly right and this
is what the media should be saying they
should be saying if you're an enemy of
Trump this is what you'd be saying about
this what you would be saying if you're
smart is this feature shows the Trump
doesn't know he's doing that he's a
volatile dope who goes on Twitter and
spouts off and is not advancing any
policy but he's catering to a base of
people who are mad and whatever and
Trump's people don't want that to be so
Trump's people are of divided mind so
I'm one hand they want to say why are
you taking it so seriously on the other
hand they want to say everyone should
take from super seriously on the left
they say we don't want to take Trump
seriously let me take but we're going to
take him super seriously like it's a
threat of violence basically I have
another wrestling Jeff that sort of
shows what exactly really is happening
in this Trump media fight right that's
actually what's happening here guess
everybody Trump is taking media in the
head and knocking them out and the media
is treating it like the media are taking
them at
they're knocking about basically they're
both masking each other out because this
is all just insane and stupid it's just
insane and stupid and one of the reasons
again that the right is responding the
way they are to Trump suite is because
of the media coverage of other violent
rhetoric right they've ignored it for
years except when it comes from the
right in which case they declared the
worst thing in the world there's a
representative named Zeldin who is on
CNN and he was being asked about all the
sea congressman Lee Zeldin I guess and
he was being asked by fredericka
Whitfield about Trump's tweet and she
won't let him talk right he says you
guys do this all the time and she won't
let him talk and you wonder why the
right is frustrated Gus this is why and
the okay what was the message should I
then I'm not here to defend the tweet
that was here that was that was there
this morning so that's why I'm giving
the answer that there's a way for the
president to be able to raise his game
but there is a you know I'm not it's not
a changing of direction that we all need
to do more to be able to raise our game
because while we're here talking about
it you have people in Hollywood making
making jokes about assassinating the
president adage punching him in the face
cutting his head off you do have people
in the media who aren't by ear there are
and you're trying very hard not to deal
with the topic at hand right now by
bringing up these other examples that
have already been Genoa at nauseam and
you're trying to ship know that is
relevant okay because that's what Trump
always says read Trump's entire defenses
I'm punching back which means that the
left needs to call out their own
rhetoric the same way that they're
calling out the rights rhetoric and the
right by the way is full of crap also
because the right does this routine
where they're very pissed that that
Barack Obama use the selfie stick in the
Oval Office totally fair okay you
shouldn't be using a selfie stick in the
Oval Office is disrespectful you can't
do that and then turn around and say
this is totally cool what Trump is doing
and we'll talk about what the
Republicans are doing wrong in just a
second but for that you're going to have
to go over to Daley wire calm and become
a subscriber so over at Daily wire calm
you can subscribe for just $8 a month
and that will get you a meiga to nad
free experience on the website it also
gets you the rest of my show live it
gets you my mailbag live which will be
doing on Friday it gets Clavin show live
as well we have another show that's
gonna premier soon which you will get
live as well
so lots of great material if you become
a subscriber and join the club if you
want to become an annual subscriber they
get a free signed copy of say it so this
book by me and my dad about baseball and
fathers and sons you can check that out
over at daily wire com make sure that
you lock in your subscription now
because July 10th the price goes up so
in like a week the price is about to
jump so right now is the time for you
get that subscription if you've been
thinking about it makes a great gift for
Dad as well especially the book and so
check that out or if you just want to
listen later over at iTunes or
SoundCloud then go over there subscribe
leave review we always appreciate it we
are the largest conservative podcast in
the nation
[Music]